Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
Jess wants two hundred ribbons of length 110 centimeters for a party
However, the ribbons were sold at 25 meters per tape how many tapes will Jess need?
This problem is sparking controversy because it was given to primary school students in Singapore.
However, many adults could not solve this problem and felt
it was too tricky to be given to 12 year old students.
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching the video for the solution.
While this problem is not too difficult,
it is fairly tricky, and I myself came up with the wrong answer by using the wrong approach.
The first pitfall is that the problem involves multiple units of measurement.
So we need to make sure to use only one unit of measurement. I will convert everything to meters.
The first step:
I'll say that the hundred and ten centimeters of each ribbon equals one point one meters for each ribbon
Next
I multiplied the one point one meters by the two hundred ribbons that were needed to get the total length of
220 meters.
I then took that total length and divided by the 25 meters per tape to get that there would be
8.8 tapes needed to produce that length.
I then said since eight tapes are too few, we would need nine tapes in total.
But this is the wrong answer.
In fact, 10 tapes are needed.
Why is that?
The reason is we shouldn't be considering just the total length of ribbon,
but we need to consider how much ribbon is used per tape.
Each tape has 25 meters
So we need to take the 25 meters per tape and divide it by the 1.1 meters per ribbon
We end up that each tape can produce 22 whole ribbons plus an excess amount.
But this is not a whole ribbon amount; it's less than one.
So each tape can make 22 whole ribbons, and then we're gonna have some excess material, which is going to be wasted.
Now technically you could try and combine this excess material between the tapes,
but nowhere in the problem does it say that you can do that. So you'd likely have to assume that the excess material
goes wasted. So you would have to say that each tape can produce 22 whole ribbons.
From there,
we know that we need 200 total ribbons so we divide that by the 22 ribbons per tape, to get that we'll need
9 + 1/11 tapes.
In other words,
we'll need more than 9 tapes since
9 tapes are too few, we will need 10 tapes to produce all the 200 ribbons.
So, this is a fairly tricky question, and
getting to the correct answer of 10 tapes requires some thoughtful process of considering the dimensions and the
excess material of each tape.
Did you figure out this problem?
Thanks for watching this video. Please subscribe to my channel;
I make videos on math. You can catch me on my blog "Mind Your Decisions"
which you can follow on Facebook, Google+ and Patreon. You can catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar
And if you like this video, please check out my books there are links in the video description